[Music]  she was called  mother earth we plundered everything she  offered  none of us should have come back  where i'm from all reproductive  technology efforts failed for both men  and women  they want to prove that we can procreate  here on earth  we came to earth on the first mission we  waited so long  it's imperative that we give future  generations the chance of civilization  and bring our people home  for the many  who are they survivors months  we called them  i saw a child  we can repopulate our planet there are  children  they won't be by the time our people  arrive  are you still with us blake  our predecessors failed us in so many  ways  are they coming  let's get out of here trust me  [Music]  you